we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p yesterday i
did a piece about twelve minutes talking
about my concern around
pseudo-intellectual ism and the sort of
environment that is very very receptive
to pseudo-intellectual ism and a lot of
people thought i was saying that sam
harris is not an intellectual let me
give you an example of one of these
messages this one came in by voicemail
early this morning hey David I just
listened to your take on the
pseudo-intellectual ISM and I agree with
most those folks that were named in that
article but Sam Harris really I
understand no ISA pseudo-intellectual is
it because he offends numerous people
and he claims that the ideas of
Christianity and Islam are completely
foolish and stupid that's the only thing
I could think of other than that I'm I'm
lost help me out David Oh doc you late
so listen I mentioned Sam Harris once in
yesterday's story merely in that he was
mentioned in a New York Times article
called the intellectual dark web web by
Barry Weiss I mentioned Sam Harris's
name and a number of other names only
insofar as I was telling you about the
article that sort of got me thinking
about the story I did yesterday
I never said yesterday that Sam Harris
is not an intellectual I've read a lot
of sam Harris's work I have some
political disagreements with Sam Harris
I think that his book the moral
landscape is endlessly fascinating I've
never really taken a position on whether
sam Harris is or isn't an intellectual I
I think I believe that he is and that's
okay to say that and still say that I
disagreed with some of the stuff that he
said my commentary yesterday was not
about saying sam Harris is not an
intellectual and if that's mostly what
you focused on you really miss the point
of my entire commentary okay so no I
never said sam Harris isn't an
intellectual I mentioned his name
yesterday in passing as one of many five
six seven different people that were
mentioned by Barry Weiss I think Steven
Pinker was mentioned I'm not saying
steven pinker is not an intellectual the
commentary was about the environment in
which pseudo intellectual ism and faux
intellectualism is sort of welcomed and
embraced by people rather than about
saying who is or isn't on the list of
intellectuals we have a great bonus show
today we'll talk about Seattle's new
head tax which will charge big companies
a fee to help the homeless we will also
talk about uber dropping its arbitration
requirements for sexual assault victims
and lastly the Trump administration is
considering housing migrant children on
military bases as a result of Jeff
Sessions getting tough on undocumented
immigration all of those stories and
more are on today's bonus show which you
can access by becoming a member at join
pakman.com if you want a discount you
can use the coupon code vote soon 18 you
can also access the bonus show by
becoming a patron at the five dollar or
higher level at patreon.com slash david
pakman show don't miss the bonus show
and don't miss all the great new t-shirt
designs available at david pakman.com
slash gear selling like hotcakes after
yesterday what are hotcakes anyways at a
type of food I don't even know he's like
a patty cake apparently they sell well
that's all I'm gonna look it up I'm
curious what is a hot cake and should I
bring one in for lunch tomorrow